i really wanted to say this to you
really quick because i know you have to
get going a huge lying everything that
i'm a [ __ ] i had the most severe
mental health illness severe alcohol
problem just away every opportunity
nobody talks to me anymore siblings
won't answer my call i made every wrong
stick no skills no talents made less
than 30 thousand dollars in my life i
know you're gonna like bash me call me a
[ __ ] loser this and that apparently
do you remember
what do you think that's gonna be what
i'm gonna say yeah i live in my parents
vacation do you actually think that was
born with every advantage world
squandered everything severe alcoholic
severe drug illness mental illness
the good news is
and you're 32. yeah anybody else in me
would be imprisoned or dead or homeless
so you must be super grateful yeah
everybody calls me a [ __ ] loser
what do you what do you call yourself
right
right
i don't know what everybody's saying you
would call me that too i definitely
wouldn't if you believe if you believe
that i said like anybody in parents they
should be off their transparent all the
time no i said anybody who shits on
their parents
and is on their payroll is full of [ __ ]
i don't mean that they're a loser yeah
let me ask you a real question what do
you feel about yourself i i made every
wrong mistake a human being could make
but i almost died from alcohol what
about what about drunk yeah of
what about the butt
but i'm still alive and uh i i could
i didn't die most people died overcame
addiction and overcame the alcoholism
right do you know how big of a [ __ ]
win that is
i admire you
[Music]
i admire you i'm shocked by your
response you bashed me that you called
me biggest [ __ ] for you to be able to
have all that adversity and be standing
in front of me what about somebody born
of every advantage one percent
how about somebody that was born with
everything advantage
[ __ ] up for 30 years of it and then
decided at 33 to [ __ ] build and then
at 50 was happy and content and
successful and teaching the world that
it's okay to [ __ ] up your first 30 years
of your life and then you could still go
and win how about that person
who's that person that's you
you really believe that why why not
like why would he i don't believe why
i'm good i'm good why i i mean i i
graduated from college and then did
nothing drink who gives literally that's
that's
all i'm all i'm hearing from you is you
talking about yesterday okay like i i
literally died
0.28 you told me nightclub almost killed
her 0.32 you literally [ __ ] you you've
established that i've woken up [ __ ]
you you've established that with me yeah
my parents been hundred thousand dollars
mental health treatment
you've established that for me
that's yesterday
but then i'm standing in front of you
today you came here for a reason yeah
yeah you must be on the precipice of
turning it around yeah i came here
because i thought you were going to like
bash me and say like and what was that
going to do for you
be another person who just kind of like
because you talk about people who come
from the dirt people like you right now
there's always born with everything
there's millions of people that i admire
that come from unbelievable wealth have
more adversity than people from the dirt
and go and win more importantly the
reason i admire you is i can't believe
that level of pain at that short period
of time and i'm feeling your energy
right here with me right now and i know
that you're on the precipice of the turn
of the turnaround the [ __ ] the
build-up you started up here you went
down here
and you can now build up here on your
own [ __ ] path with all that behind
you you can help people and you can
start with yourself
bro you're [ __ ] you are [ __ ]
in the best position ever you know
exactly what the dark side tastes like
you've got that all behind you now
you've got nothing but [ __ ]
opportunity now
now it's about earning all that trust
back
now it's about doing things for a long
enough period of time that are on the
right way
that all the people that love you more
than life
start answering those questions and
those phone calls
and that your parents wake up and say
thank god we put all of it on the line
because look at our son now is actually
doing it
i'm proud of you
i've shot great response well honestly
like bash me [ __ ] criticism
why because people like you grew up in
the dirt you grew up in belarus [ __ ] me
i'm one person yeah but guess what right
but guess what i admire you because you
grew up with i grew up with chemicals
that made me have no shot of losing you
grew up with certain chemicals that put
you in a vulnerable spot but the fact
that you didn't succumb like so many
billions of others and now you're on
your build up back i admire that show
i'm really shocked
honestly completely shocked
all right brother
of course all right wish you well